as a public defender's Robin Steinberg
public defender for over 30 years and
someone who spent a lot of time thinking
about the bail system you had to very
often defend people who sometimes had
committed heinous crimes how did you
defend these people what I learned over
40 years was that the charge that
somebody comes into the criminal justice
system with is just the beginning of the
inquiry the real question is what lays
behind the charge and who is that person
we tend to you know demonize them and
forget that they are also part of our
human community and to lean into that
experience which is really at the end of
the day the only thing that connects us
is people
[Music]